20-17 was an amazing year for csgo from
gambits incredible run at the Cracow
major to eske's returned to the very top
of counter-strike so to celebrate the
best player storylines this year we put
together a list of the top 10 kicking
off our list at number 10 is swag now
swags 2017 was not very eventful
but for swag one of the most famous
players permanently banned by valve 2017
brought an important change
this summer ESL and Dreamhack announced
they would unbanned swag and other
former iBUYPOWER players from their
events the move gave his fans some hope
that they may see the CS prodigy on some
of the biggest stages in the game once
again despite still being banned by
valve and that CS summit swag showed us
that he still has what it takes to
compete with the best in the world oh
shut up swag number 9 on our list
gobby the in-game leader for big had an
unexpectedly strong year placing 2nd at
to dream hacks and winning the minor
championship for the crack of major but
perhaps most unexpectedly Gavi took an
underrated roster of misfits to legend
status at the major when they made it to
quarterfinals there was some controversy
surrounding big at the major when they
utilize the jump bug during the group
stage that allowed invisible and
soundless speaking on some maps but
after a gentlemen's agreement between
teams to not use the bug big still
defeated SK 2 3-0 the group stage
Scott beginning to and though they fell
in the top eight gobby and big have
guaranteed themselves a spot at the next
major in Boston and we're excited to see
what 2018 could bring for them just go
for a flash man goes in this is where he
has to try strike now guess the timing
fight one kill what's the second the
double attack olofmeister comes in at
number eight on our list once widely
regarded as the best player in the world
olaf joined phase in august after a
somewhat lackluster end to his time with
fnatic it is like starting over again
and that's something that I guess I
needed I get this feeling of a little
bit nervous again and that's something I
have been missing just wanna say and
since joining phase Olaf has proven he's
still one of the best helping the team
when ESL one New York and the Ely
premier also placing second at IEM
Oakland phase still have a lot to prove
if they want to live up to their
potential but all eyes will be on this
team and olofmeister heading into the
Boston Major
he secures around single-handedly and
the legend returns it shows us what he's
made of that should be a closer a Mike
at this Frank but not meant to be what
an epic performance of Olaf get right
has not had a good year but he ended the
year with a redemption story and that's
why he is number 7 on our list after
missing out on their third consecutive
major by falling in the online
qualifiers for Boston in October get
Wright was heartbroken and won't be
going to the EU miner saying there is
nothing more to say then this is
soul-crushing don't really have any
words but his play at IEM
Auckland in November showed that the
organization that first dominated csgo
still has a bit of fight left in the
team
I pledged to fight
against the best in the world
number six on our list is electronic
long seen as a bright star on a
struggling flipside tactics electronic
finally got his big break this year just
an electronic left it's right side drink
electronic what are you doing there's a
quad kill for electronic who even
finishes up the job
what are nuts play from electronic
joining a navi roster that has a lot of
potential with navi electronic place
12th at season six of pro-league and one
dreamhack winter
na'vi has not quite lived up to the hype
surrounding their roster but their win
at Dreamhack winter represented signs of
life for the squad and electronic may
have finally found a team where he can
really shine electronic is exploding in
this round and Navi could be on the
brink of a victory now it's all down to
Nikko he's been spotted in electronic
he's not gonna get the ACE but Eddie
takes it away it doesn't matter in the
end playing with two Brazilian squads in
2017 bolts comes in at number five on
our list with the mortals he placed
third to fourth at the IEM World
Championship in Katowice and second at
the crack of major but big results aside
bolts story this year revolves around
the roster shake ups after immortals
Brazilian csgo team effectively
dissolved despite their strong
performances first it's no secret to
anyone that follows csgo that our roster
has been undergoing some difficulties
over the last few months with many ex
immortals players joining new teams
bolts was the most successful of his
former teammates in the latter half of
2017 returning to his former luminosity
gaming teammates on SK with SK bolts one
epicenter and blast Pro Series
Copenhagen and placed third to fourth at
IEM Oakland for fans of the Brazilian
scene bolts returned to fallen and the
rest of sk was thrilling
but equally thrilling was his
performance what a comeback from 12 3 in
the first half these rounds are so
incredibly close fall and just barely
stops the ball plant before he goes down
bullets no.1 on 3 gets a kill coming in
at number 4 on our list
Zeus rose to the highest highs of
counter-strike in 2017 he won the crack
of major with gambit and
had somewhat more measured results with
Navi though he did win Dreamhack winter
2017
Navi are your champions in an exquisite
2-0 performance and throughout this
entire event they
but for Zeus the winning Krakov was the
culmination of a year-long promise to
himself you tweeted I will not give up
till a win a mother bit in nature you
just did that
now what are you gonna do I just saved
all of my semi-loyal and second North
help me and they wore measure
Zeus is leadership on gambit was central
to their victory at the major and though
he has since returned to Navi to
somewhat mixed results his win with
gambit at Krakov after his colorful
declaration almost a year earlier helped
to define his 2017 along with an always
strong SK gaming fir had a very strong
2017 placing second at Dreamhack masters
and then winning IEM Sydney ECS season 3
ESL one cologne epicenter and blast pro
series Copenhagen they had a somewhat
weaker showing at the majors this year
placing top four at eleague and top
eight at crack of fir has always been an
excellent player on an excellent team
but in 2017 he really cemented himself
as one of the core stars that made this
SK roster so successful with SK looking
to make a splash at the e League major
in Boston 2018 there's no question that
fir will be front and center but also
just days except well I know where your
heads are falling I'll just stay right
here ball a thing I've ever seen doesn't
even press anything number 2 on our list
device had a 20-17 that saw him in peak
form winning the Ely major and the IEM
World Championship in Katowice he also
placed a four at Krakov but what should
have been the landmark year for the
prodigal oper talk a sour note when he
was forced to take a break due to
medical issues with astralis playing a
series of stand-ins device has had to
take a back seat at the end of 2017
though he is confirmed he'll be playing
in the next major it's not clear what
his health will permit
[Applause]
it's a bitter end of the year for one of
the game's strongest players we can only
hope he'll be back in full force in 2018
sip lights with doing one round that's
insane and he's gonna get the defuse on
the back of it as well that is absolute
pandemonium surprising no one nico
rounds out our list at number one
starting the season off with a
struggling mousesports nico placed 12th
to 14th at the e league major an after
joining faze clan they also struggled at
the crack of major placing 15th to 16th
but a late season resurgence saw them
finish 1st at ESL one New York and the E
league premier second at IEM Auckland
and third at blast Pro Series copenhagen
nikos 2017 saw the realization of his
enormous potential long scene as the
primary carry on the former Maus roster
yesterday quickly without response he's
an acquaintance janani coach got all
three though the new faze clan took some
time to gel they look like one of the
strongest teams in the world and Nico's
play has been a huge part of that he
does not even need the limit
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button